[SPEAKER_01]: Every day you make choices.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some choices seem small.
[SPEAKER_00]: Drugs don't just affect one moment.
[SPEAKER_00]: They affect your future.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have goals.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have potential.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't let substances decide for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Choose your future.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stay known to alcohol, marijuana, and drugs.
[SPEAKER_07]: and Central in their class for doing that campaign for us, and thank all the youth who did their stuff outside of the school.
[SPEAKER_07]: In or out, we don't care where we get you guys involved at, we just want you involved.
[SPEAKER_07]: Outside of the classroom, that Richmond Middle School also did a Read Easier campaign, which is a peer-to-peer saturation campaign for middle school students
[SPEAKER_07]: that educates on the harmful effects of nicotine by youth.
[SPEAKER_07]: It was a three-day saturation that included posters on the walls throughout the school, announcements throughout the day, and an interactive lunch event.
[SPEAKER_07]: And Word held a school-wide Change the Box.
[SPEAKER_07]: The student council put that on.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's a three-day event on making healthy choices, preventing substance use, and building a stronger school-wide relationship.
[SPEAKER_07]: Additionally, we did prom boxes.
[SPEAKER_07]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, in the school we had 530 students reach through 15 presentations.
[SPEAKER_07]: Richmond's Breathe Easier campaign.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oryx campaign.
[SPEAKER_07]: And the prom check boxes, those were sent out to all schools for their prominence and their prom cards and posters.
[SPEAKER_07]: Historically, we've also done a pledge where they won't use drugs or alcohol surrounding prom.
[SPEAKER_07]: We have a vaping campaign that we do that you've probably seen us on Facebook.
[SPEAKER_07]: If you haven't, please join us on Facebook.
[SPEAKER_07]: As a mom, I've kind of had that problem of how do I address this with my kids?
[SPEAKER_07]: What do I say to them?
[SPEAKER_07]: How do I say this right?
[SPEAKER_07]: And this gives us a lot of ideas.
[SPEAKER_07]: Parent Up is a great campaign that really helps, it's helped me, like how do I have this conversation with my kids and not just sound like mom?
[SPEAKER_07]: But then after my kids hear it, then they get to go to school and they get to tell their fears, because that's really what matters, right?
[SPEAKER_07]: Mom can say whatever she wants to, but if your peers say something different, so it's really hitting one kiddo because they can make a difference for their entire group.
[SPEAKER_07]: There's our underage drinking campaign, again, surrounding prom.
[SPEAKER_07]: We also have one surrounding graduation.
[SPEAKER_07]: We know those are big party times.
[SPEAKER_07]: And then I'm going to have Chelsea Lane come up.
[SPEAKER_07]: She's been working with the juvenile office with us for some family workshops.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hello, my name is Chelsea Lane with the Nurture Path, and I'm the proud provider of a couple workshops here in Ray County.
[SPEAKER_04]: I also worked in the Excelsior Springs School District for the past, I don't know,
[SPEAKER_04]: a lot of years, 12, 13 something years.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna be the principal at the Early Childhood Center next year.
[SPEAKER_04]: So while I do not live in Wright County, I have a lot of children and families that live in Wright County that mean a lot to me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Last year, we established a partnership in Ray County to offer a couple different classes with the hope to provide skills needed for self-regulation, healthy relationships, staying out of trouble, you know, all the things in Ray County.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I currently offer two classes here.
[SPEAKER_04]: One is a class focused on teenagers, which is called Mind Over Mood.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the other is a class focused on parents or grandparents or family caregivers that's called Parenting Through Tough Times.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm going to just tell you a little bit about each of those classes.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Parenting Through Tough Times is a virtual class that we offer through Zoom.
[SPEAKER_04]: Originally, I also offer classes in Clay County and Platt County, and we have tried variations of this class in person.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's just a lot of barriers with people being able to get there, or being able to come to both classes, or just things popping up and happening.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we decided to try virtual, and that's gone really well, because they must be tuned in from anywhere.
[SPEAKER_04]: So anybody is allowed to register for the class if they just want to listen in, if they're hoping to just spark a little something that would be helpful with them on their parenting journey.
[SPEAKER_04]: But if families would like a, we do offer a certificate of completion if they want that, and we just ask that they're an active participant.
[SPEAKER_04]: What we mean by that is I just always say that to show signs of life through the class.
[SPEAKER_04]: So since it is virtual, they do have to either unmute and talk or use the chat and just show that they're really listening and reflecting and thinking about how the things that we're talking about apply to their family.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sometimes on the virtual platform, I feel like that makes people a little braver too, like they're not sitting across from someone that might be judging something that you're sharing about your family.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so that's a really nice safe space for families.
[SPEAKER_04]: In the adult class, we really focus on that adult first mindset shift.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we talk a lot about the brain, how our brain is wired, how our experiences shape the way we view, react, and respond to the world.
[SPEAKER_04]: We talk a lot about how the way that we are parented affects the way we parent, affects our children.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just really kind of understanding all those different lines of relationships and communication.
[SPEAKER_04]: We talk a lot about identifying triggers and maybe what emotions sometimes be emotional for people.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sometimes it can be really empowering for people.
[SPEAKER_04]: Overall, we get a lot of really nice feedback.
[SPEAKER_04]: I almost always receive a personal message after a class about how it was really helpful or it was just okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: they needed, or they felt like it made a difference right away in their ability to communicate, or to maybe even see their children's behavior a little bit differently and try to approach things.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I just put a couple of nice words up here about how families have used this information to strengthen their relationship with their children.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that is wonderful, because we need that.
[SPEAKER_04]: On the other side, you have the Mine and Remove class, which is a class focused for teens.
[SPEAKER_04]: This class in Ray County is held at the Ray County Library.
[SPEAKER_04]: They've been great hosts for us there.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a great space.
[SPEAKER_04]: We also started, have the opportunity to provide pizza, which is a big hit, you know, everybody loves pizza.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's been nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: This class is also two sessions.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can't remember if I said that for the first one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Both classes are two sessions, one and a half hour each.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we learned a lot of things, we digested, I gave them some little things to think about or practice for the week, and then they come back the next week.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so same thing with the team class.
[SPEAKER_04]: This one is, they're structured very similarly, and that is intentional, that if a teen is taking a class, my parents do that, so I see them like, good news, we have a class for them too, it's perfect.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plans behind our behavior, it feels a little bit less personal.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the Mind Over Mood class, sometimes I say kids are voluntold, so they're not super pumped to be there, but they do show up, and that's great.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we have that partnership with the juvenile office, and I think the first ever diversion class that they, yes, okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Or at least the first in several years.
[SPEAKER_04]: The first that we could find.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that was very exciting that we were able to offer teens that are really struggling with making good decisions, healthy communication.
[SPEAKER_04]: Maybe they're struggling in a class, testing them out, vandalizing, you know, whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: But we talk about those things and how our brain states and our emotions kind of dictate our behaviors.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have to get these things in check so we can get our behavior in check.
[SPEAKER_04]: And there's a lot more to getting our behavior in check than just staying out of trouble, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Increases our ability to have friends, you know, kind of what emotions go upward.
[SPEAKER_04]: The library had to kick us out because they were closing.
[SPEAKER_04]: And one of the teams was just really, like, talking about all these things.
[SPEAKER_04]: It was so wonderful.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ashley from the juvenile office was like, I have never heard them talk that much.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I was like, oh, that's so fun.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're having to make a sleeve for them to have fun.
[SPEAKER_04]: Mind over mood, but they will never act like they have fun, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: They show up like they would rather be anywhere else.
[SPEAKER_04]: But when they leave too, they often have a lot of nice things to say.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I think that's sweet.
[SPEAKER_04]: That was a little sour patch of people.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I put some nice words up here that they said just about how the class helps them feel more confident and how to express their feelings or how to approach a situation or maybe not take something so personally seriously.
[SPEAKER_04]: realize when we do regulate our emotions, right, we're able to think a little bit more simply before we react or respond.
[SPEAKER_04]: So both those classes really work together for intervention efforts at Ray County to really just help develop skills within people instead of just punishing or doing responsive efforts to something that's already happened.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the goal of these classes would be
[SPEAKER_04]: When the situation arises, you have other tools in your toolbox to use to navigate those problems.
[SPEAKER_04]: Healthy communication within the family, and then of course those strong foundational pieces for self-regulation and realizing that taking a deep breath isn't just totally woo-woo, which is actually very helpful, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: And just really getting more comfortable and confident with being able to do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we know when we do all those things that we have strong families.
[SPEAKER_04]: When we have strong families, we have strong communities.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, hey, thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: The funding for these classes comes through Beacon Mental Health, which we are one of four agencies in the state who got some prevention funding from the opioid settlement dollars, so the pharmaceutical company all had to pay out for all the harm caused by the opioid epidemic, and the state of Missouri got some of that funding, and Beacon was actually one of the four agencies that got the prevention funding, so if you hear any talk about that, just make sure you know that it's
[SPEAKER_05]: And I oversee those dollars, and I put a lot of it in my county.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm really trying to help make sure that we can provide some programming like Toby provides here.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, just because we're at something where, you know, legislators have power over how these dollars are allocated, know that this money is going to impact your area.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_07]: Anybody have any questions about things that I, as I was sitting there, realized how fast I talked?
[SPEAKER_07]: Questions, things you want us to go back over?
[SPEAKER_07]: Questions you have for Chelsea on what she does?
[SPEAKER_07]: I will tell you, a little more self-disclosure, a few years ago I was sitting in the coalition and we were talking about what we do as parents impacts our children.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah, we all know that, right?
[SPEAKER_07]: And then they were talking about what do you do whenever you have a bad day?
[SPEAKER_07]: Do you go home and have a glass of wine?
[SPEAKER_07]: Do you go home and do this?
[SPEAKER_07]: Do you go home and do that?
[SPEAKER_07]: And I thought, huh.
[SPEAKER_07]: Go to the Mexican restaurant and have a margarita.
[SPEAKER_07]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_07]: Nice fun fact to point out.
[SPEAKER_07]: And then a couple years later, my kids talk about how, Mom, we see you drunk.
[SPEAKER_07]: We don't ever see Dad drunk.
[SPEAKER_07]: My kids instinctively thought mom going to Mexican and having a margarita, whether they knew I was having a bad day or not, assumed that mom was getting drunk every single time she had a margarita.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I had to take that time to explain to my children responsible drinking.
[SPEAKER_07]: Mom doesn't go to the Mexican restaurant to have a pitcher of margaritas by herself.
[SPEAKER_07]: Mom starts driving you home after she's had a pitcher of margaritas.
[SPEAKER_07]: Mom is going and having a drink.
[SPEAKER_07]: Adults over 21 get to have a drink.
[SPEAKER_07]: We're not abusing it.
[SPEAKER_07]: There are ways to drink responsibly.
[SPEAKER_07]: But it was interesting to me for my children to throw in my face what I was trying to do with all of you guys, and then my kids are like, well, Mom, you do this.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, not really, but thanks a lot.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, think about those things.
[SPEAKER_07]: Again, I had never thought about it until we were sitting in some meeting, and it was brought up, and then my kids throw it in my face, and I'm like, yeah, that's what we're trying to not teach.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, we've also talked about with the coalition for several years, yes, as adults who are on the coalition, we may be seen out in public having age rape.
[SPEAKER_07]: Again, we're talking about responsible usage.
[SPEAKER_07]: Kids are not responsible to use under the age of 18 because no substance is legal for them to use under the age of 18.
[SPEAKER_07]: So please don't mishear our message on drinking and smoking and all of that stuff.
[SPEAKER_07]: If you are over the age of 21, please feel free to do what it is that you do in a responsible manner so that we're teaching our children responsible adult decisions.
[SPEAKER_07]: All right, with that...
[SPEAKER_07]: We're going to start the Canada's Forum.
[SPEAKER_07]: But I want to start out pretty clearly as what we are and what we are not doing here.
[SPEAKER_07]: Number one, this is nonpartisan.
[SPEAKER_07]: And it is for educational information only.
[SPEAKER_07]: We are not here to debate politics.
[SPEAKER_07]: I know it's a pretty heavy subject in the world whenever you walk out these doors.
[SPEAKER_07]: We're not going to solve all those problems today, and I don't even want to really touch much on them today.
[SPEAKER_07]: What we do want to focus on are the problems that we have going on here in Ray County, and we want it to be surrounded.
[SPEAKER_07]: We've given all the candidates some questions, given them some time to mull around their thoughts on that.
[SPEAKER_07]: So that's going to be our focus.
[SPEAKER_07]: Our focus is on Ray County youth and how do we make Ray County the best county for these children.
[SPEAKER_07]: What else was I going to say?
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_07]: We did send invitations to all candidates.
[SPEAKER_07]: Historically, we have only focused on commissioners and legislators, judges and prosecutors.
[SPEAKER_07]: However, this year we went ahead and we opened it up to all of our counties.
[SPEAKER_07]: So county clerk, county recorder, county treasurer.
[SPEAKER_07]: county collector, circuit clerk, associate judge, prosecuting attorney, presiding commissioners, and the Missouri House of Representatives.
[SPEAKER_07]: So we want everyone to share their voice because we don't know who is that one person that might spark the church.
[SPEAKER_07]: We want to be respectful of everybody's time today.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I'll have the format up here, hopefully.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll pop it.
[SPEAKER_07]: We do want to acknowledge Representative McGaugh.
[SPEAKER_07]: This is her last year.
[SPEAKER_07]: She's unfortunately terming out.
[SPEAKER_07]: But Peggy has done a lot of things to support us throughout the year.
[SPEAKER_07]: She's done a lot of things to support Lane County.
[SPEAKER_07]: So we want to thank her for her time and attention that she's given to us.
[SPEAKER_07]: I know sometimes it feels like when our legislators go down to Jeff City, they kind of forget where they came from.
[SPEAKER_07]: And we just want to thank Peggy for not forgetting people that she left behind whenever she went down.
[SPEAKER_07]: So we're going to do one minute for introductions, and then you'll have three minutes to answer your questions.
[SPEAKER_07]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_07]: So we will start with presenting commissioners.
[SPEAKER_07]: So if Brianna Roth could come forward.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ronald White, Ben Alrich, and Gary Wilhite, whose names I put here.
[SPEAKER_07]: If everybody could come forward, please.
[SPEAKER_07]: Also, please, there's a lot of food left.
[SPEAKER_07]: Please feel free to fill up your plates again.
[SPEAKER_07]: Whatever you need to do while people are talking.
[SPEAKER_07]: We will have, Emily, are you going to have the timer back on?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Emily will be your girl back in the corner.
[SPEAKER_07]: I believe it's a 30-second warning that you're going to give.
[SPEAKER_07]: Is that right?
Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: All right.
[SPEAKER_07]: So if you guys will start, Brianna, if you will start with your introduction and what motivated you to run for President of the United States.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: My name is Brianna Rock.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm from Lawson, Missouri.
[SPEAKER_06]: I actually grew up in Kearney, but moved to Lawson in 2018, trying to move rural and get school districts back where we landed with a little piece of ground.
[SPEAKER_06]: I went back to college late in life and graduated from Lane Jewel in the field of psychology, but life took a different route.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm married.
[SPEAKER_06]: I have three children, two grandsons, and another one on the way that are my joy.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm an insurance agent at Missouri Park Bureau.
[SPEAKER_06]: In 2020, there was mental health issues abounded, and we really started taking a look at where are we spending our money.
[SPEAKER_10]: I've been hiring at Ford Motor Company for about 26 years.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'm a veteran of the United States Army National Guard for six years.
[SPEAKER_10]: And presently, I'm a CalCAS operator in Eastern Grayville.
[SPEAKER_10]: I farm over there.
[SPEAKER_10]: And why I run for commission is like that.
[SPEAKER_10]: But anyway, I see a need that people come to me and ask me what I think.
[SPEAKER_10]: I try to give my very best answer.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'm a yes.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'm not a yes man.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'm a total guy that needs to tell you straightforward what I think.
[SPEAKER_10]: So if you've got a question, I'll answer it to the best of my ability.
[SPEAKER_10]: But anyway, I've been married for years.
[SPEAKER_10]: 54 years.
[SPEAKER_10]: My wife over here raised the family and I've seen it all.
[SPEAKER_10]: I've raised the kids and grandkids and I see the need for accounting and I just feel like I'm qualified to do it.
[SPEAKER_10]: Things I've done through my years of life.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you, Ben.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm so sorry.
[SPEAKER_07]: I was looking.
[SPEAKER_07]: I was getting prepared for you, Ben.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_07]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_08]: My name is Ben Aldridge.
[SPEAKER_08]: I just retired from Murphy Tractor and Equipment.
[SPEAKER_08]: I think there's some John Deere equipment.
[SPEAKER_08]: I assume you'll see your county board.
[SPEAKER_08]: You have a lot of John Deere equipment there.
[SPEAKER_08]: I was one of them.
[SPEAKER_08]: And that's kind of the reason why I'm on it.
[SPEAKER_08]: The county has given me a lot of stuff.
[SPEAKER_08]: They're good to me.
[SPEAKER_08]: And so I just want to give back.
[SPEAKER_08]: I have no real agenda or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_08]: I just, the county's been good to our family.
[SPEAKER_08]: My wife and I have been married for 43 years.
[SPEAKER_08]: I just want to give back.
[SPEAKER_08]: That's kind of it.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Gary?
[SPEAKER_09]: My name is Gary Braulight.
[SPEAKER_09]: I have been a presiding commissioner previously for four years, western commissioner for four years.
[SPEAKER_09]: And the third time that I ran, which was four, presiding commissioner, I lost by seven votes.
[SPEAKER_09]: I had the right for a recount.
[SPEAKER_09]: The recount would have cost the taxpayers $15,000.
[SPEAKER_09]: And I said, no, I'm not going to spend their money for that.
[SPEAKER_09]: I'll wait for four years, then I'll do my thing again.
[SPEAKER_09]: So I have the experience.
[SPEAKER_09]: I've spent, like I said, eight years there.
[SPEAKER_09]: And I actually receive people calling me on the phone and texting me telling me, you've got to go up there and do something because these people don't know what's going on.
[SPEAKER_09]: So on behalf of, just not them, but on behalf of Great County, I know that
[SPEAKER_09]: how the system works, and I know what we have to do.
[SPEAKER_09]: And therefore, I'm going back to try to pick up what's been going wrong and correct it.
[SPEAKER_09]: And again, this would be my fourth term I ran, and I don't know, I've always, when I first took office, the county was 175,000 in the whole of general revenue.
[SPEAKER_09]: The group before me made up the year after, the first year that I was there, saved the budget and voted on it so it couldn't be changed.
[SPEAKER_09]: So I took third budget, which was $175,000 in the home, and after my last term, I left general revenue with $2.1 million.
[SPEAKER_09]: We were able to be able to buy a lot of equipment from Ben to keep equipment up to take care of our roads.
[SPEAKER_09]: So, on behalf of his family, everything kind of started to pass.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I was very fortunate.
[SPEAKER_08]: I was brought up in a religious family.
[SPEAKER_08]: When you start there and move forward from that, I think is a good choice.
[SPEAKER_08]: With your organization here, I think that as big as you are and what you're doing, that it would have to be worked closely with folks.
[SPEAKER_08]: Because you've got more eye and ears on it than anybody else does.
[SPEAKER_08]: So I'd say that would be one of the things is when you folks get involved in being there in the forefront, that they would be like, we're posting with you, and how you're doing what you can.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you, Bill.
[SPEAKER_07]: We appreciate that.
[SPEAKER_07]: Gary?
[SPEAKER_09]: Oh, I get to use the same question?
[SPEAKER_09]: Yep, same question.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_09]: I kind of say, not the same thing the paper said, but I also want to include in there that things like this that pertain to the budget
[SPEAKER_09]: Those type of things, we would really appreciate your group being on the agenda to come and visit with the presiding commissioner and the eastern and western.
[SPEAKER_09]: And make your spiel to them because they are the three who will make the decision what they do with the money.
[SPEAKER_09]: And I can tell you that I've had...
[SPEAKER_09]: Relatives that's been in some difficult, very difficult situations and stuff.
[SPEAKER_09]: And for us to be able to really support you, you really need to set it up with...
[SPEAKER_09]: the commissioners so that we have it posted 24 hours and then people can come in.
[SPEAKER_09]: I'm not going to be like Sheila that's out there when you say 9 o'clock to 9.30 and 9.15 she tells all the 4-H people, get out.
[SPEAKER_09]: You've got to get out here.
[SPEAKER_09]: We've got somebody coming in at 9.30.
[SPEAKER_09]: Agenda said that we're supposed to be there until 9.30.
[SPEAKER_09]: They don't pay attention.
[SPEAKER_09]: They just do whatever.
[SPEAKER_09]: And it's time to get this county back to where it's going to be able to do what needs to be done.
[SPEAKER_09]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Brianna?
[SPEAKER_06]: I thought a lot about this.
[SPEAKER_06]: Our family actually used services in my family for some of the things and I don't know anybody that isn't touched by it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, sorry.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's a critical issue.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's serious and it's complicated.
[SPEAKER_06]: But my family did use services in Ray County.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you talked about the holistic part.
[SPEAKER_06]: So part of it is we do need these services.
[SPEAKER_06]: And there is a big struggle just in our state of affording and supporting that as well as important.
[SPEAKER_07]: Finally, we're on.
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah, I was very impressed with the presentation so far today.
[SPEAKER_10]: the availability of the services that are out there, that I didn't realize that Beacon was providing all these things, and to do the coalition and what they're doing in town.
[SPEAKER_10]: So I think it starts with communication and conversation.
[SPEAKER_10]: It does start at home.
[SPEAKER_10]: It starts with your kids.
[SPEAKER_10]: It starts at church.
[SPEAKER_10]: It starts at school, preschool.
[SPEAKER_10]: And I was thinking about it myself, and I think, you know, if it's just a way to communicate to all the kids and tell them the bad facts about this instead of the good things,
[SPEAKER_10]: We might be able to keep somebody from going beyond where they need to be going.
[SPEAKER_10]: So I hear that we can really, really do to help and stay focused on the kids.
[SPEAKER_10]: So that anyway, there's things like law enforcement, get information from them on how much activity you're seeing because of drugs and stuff like this and the mental health thing.
[SPEAKER_10]: That one really hit home to me, and I got to talking about it with my wife and reading about it.
[SPEAKER_10]: I did not realize the statistics was so astonishing on the mental health issues in our schools.
[SPEAKER_10]: Out of the state of Missouri, of all the kids that was surveyed, 40% of these kids had considered suicide.
[SPEAKER_10]: And what's really, really staggering and really upset me, and got me thinking the most is,
[SPEAKER_10]: The number two cause of death of the children between the ages of 7 and 17 is suicide.
[SPEAKER_10]: So I would be focused on anything and all possibilities and all the services we can provide to these kids in Ray County and the collective.
[SPEAKER_10]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Juan, you can hold on to that because I'm going to let you lead us off next time.
[SPEAKER_10]: What is it they do in programs that they can come up with and also maybe get a group together in a committee form just for the focus on this and work with the juvenile officers to see what their needs are?
[SPEAKER_09]: and just to provide the best that we possibly can to be in the good stewards of the children of this county thank you thank you jerry i'll let you go next okay i don't need that i have to i have to agree basically with everything that is being said and i emphasize that for this to happen with the commission always contact the courthouse talk
[SPEAKER_09]: to get set up on the agenda.
[SPEAKER_09]: Because that's the only way that the county can do business is off of an agenda that has to be posted 24 hours in advance to get everybody to notice to come
[SPEAKER_09]: And trust me, if I'm elected, I won't tell them in 15 minutes, get out of here, you're out of time.
[SPEAKER_09]: It's not right.
[SPEAKER_09]: But that happens up there constantly.
[SPEAKER_09]: And that would give the county and you all the chance to tell us what do you need and what can we do to help.
[SPEAKER_09]: And then we have to go and, of course, everything that you do, you have to check to be sure of general revenue.
[SPEAKER_09]: and you don't go over the budget.
[SPEAKER_09]: But I know exactly what you're talking about, and I push that whatever we can do, the county can do, we're going to do the budget.
[SPEAKER_09]: And if you do those three things for the community, things are going to work out.
[SPEAKER_09]: But if you don't,
[SPEAKER_09]: You're going to go and ask, oh boy, now we're going to have to start all over again.
[SPEAKER_09]: So that's all that I really have to say is that get the county involved with you.
[SPEAKER_09]: That's what you've got to do.
[SPEAKER_09]: Thank you, Gary.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ben?
[SPEAKER_08]: There's a question for you.
[SPEAKER_07]: What is one accounting level policy, partnership, or funding priority you would support to help prevent youth substance use and improve youth mental health?
[SPEAKER_08]: You know, I guess when you say that, my thinking is, if I understand this right, you're looking for some, what are you going to put effort into?
[SPEAKER_08]: What kind of organization do you want to put it into?
[SPEAKER_08]: On my side of this deal, I'm kind of...
[SPEAKER_08]: I know things have changed a little bit from the 4-inch and FFA, but I'm big on the agriculture world.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I think other farmers and that group of people struggle because of some of the things that are happening.
[SPEAKER_08]: They just sometimes don't get the help they need.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I think that's where...
[SPEAKER_08]: Just getting involved with some of more of that.
[SPEAKER_08]: I've seen the full range of Boston and FFA.
[SPEAKER_08]: You're dealing with people that kind of know how to work and know that it takes work to get something done.
[SPEAKER_08]: And so I kind of think that I would help try to lean a little farther that way.
[SPEAKER_08]: Town needs it.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm not arguing that.
[SPEAKER_08]: But I mean, it's just that the agriculture world is, you know, a tough world.
[SPEAKER_08]: I mean, the kids basically, how I was, you know, when I'm big enough to do stuff, that's what I do.
[SPEAKER_08]: I help my grandpa and people.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I think that's where you need more interaction with people a little older to understand.
[SPEAKER_08]: And the ag world, I think, sometimes don't get that.
[SPEAKER_08]: And don't get exposed to stuff like this.
[SPEAKER_08]: Like I said, it may not be the right answer, but the answer is that I like the ag world.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm around that.
[SPEAKER_08]: I like it.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I think those kids need a lot of help.
[SPEAKER_08]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Brianna?
[SPEAKER_06]: That is, again, a big, I can't just say one thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's going to take a village, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: We can't just attack this from one way.
[SPEAKER_06]: Recently, the commissioners, they adopted a similar ordinance or, I guess, a declaration about this drug that you're talking about.
[SPEAKER_06]: I had no idea it was here.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't understand how that's happening.
[SPEAKER_06]: When my kids were in school, they were passed around a babe on the bus.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like, what is happening?
[SPEAKER_06]: It's going to take awareness because we can't fix what we don't know is happening.
[SPEAKER_06]: So supporting the people that are out there being the boots on the ground, spreading awareness and education and supporting that is going to be important.
[SPEAKER_06]: But also the protective things of giving kids a healthy space to be in.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've got a mama's heart.
[SPEAKER_06]: My grandbabies are my joy.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I think it does start early.
[SPEAKER_06]: The earlier that you can get and put healthy protective measures around kids, even when they're coming from a complicated or difficult or even abusive home, start to see those trends going in this direction.
[SPEAKER_06]: But it's going to take a lot, but it's a priority, I'll just say.
[SPEAKER_06]: And what I can do...
[SPEAKER_07]: when it comes to budgetary issues is be protective of those matters instead of discussing about them for sure thank you very much thank you all for being here all right next we're going to have our county leadership come up um the only person that we have here today i think is kurt
[SPEAKER_07]: I think probably everybody has to go back to work, which they may not want to do either.
[SPEAKER_07]: But I'll give you one minute to talk about yourself and why you're running for office, and then I'll have a question for you.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, so my name is Kirk Troy.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm a musician and member over at Rayville Christian Union.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm a husband and a father of twins.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm also a software engineer and a regenerative rancher.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've been a software engineer for over a decade, and the reason that I bring that up is because if you grab one of those cards I have, I've already built all the software that I intended in my past life.
[SPEAKER_03]: and publish them and show them what we can do in this county with software.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is a technical role.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is not a partisan role.
[SPEAKER_03]: It is purely technical.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's not really any policy.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I built a budget explorer on there.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's a road reporting tool that I built.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then after the county saw what I did, they went and built their own, even though I offered to do it for them for free.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've been live streaming the commissioner's meetings and publishing those as a podcast, getting a lot of flack for that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I also built a client auditing tool so that if they publish a budget one day, then okay, so I'm a technical guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: My answer is kind of technical.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I would advocate for evidence-based prevention programs like the Strength in Families one that my wife runs or teaches in Excelsior Springs.
[SPEAKER_03]: one of these things.
[SPEAKER_03]: They help kids relate to their parents.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, for example, if you...
[SPEAKER_03]: don't reach mutually agreed upon goals, then you're going to have stress and strain on that parent relationship.
[SPEAKER_03]: And those people are supposed to be the caring adult in their life, which is one of the most important preventative measures for youth mental health.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then the second point is about any ongoing partnership, however often.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think some of the services that you can provide, those evidence-based programs, already have those built into them.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is a little more controversial third point, but I think preaching abstinence and
[SPEAKER_03]: certain situations is counterproductive.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, we want kids to put off substance abuse and alcohol use for as long as possible.
[SPEAKER_03]: But for those who don't choose that lifestyle, we need to keep the door open.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that means that I chose to run for clerk was that in October, we had these twins and I came to the conclusion that, hey, whenever they turn 18, I want them to be able to stay here and live here and be a part of our farm.
[SPEAKER_03]: But the way this county is going with
[SPEAKER_03]: the population is declining, the businesses not wanting to come here, there's not going to be work if things keep going the way that they need to do to make this county a place for these kids that we're talking about, and my kids, is transparency.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to, as a community, be able to know what is going on in our courthouse.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a first step.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just knowing everyone has to know what's going on.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so that's my answer.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you very much.
We appreciate you coming today.
Yes.
Thank you.
Your housekeeper of the day is Jeremy Clevenger.
[SPEAKER_07]: You will come up, sir.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, you start by telling us which area you're covering, because I think that's great.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this district, I'm Jeremy Cloutier, and my wife Heather is here with me today.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have two boys.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're 17 and 14.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know she looks young, but we have been married 19 years.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I want to clear that up.
[SPEAKER_02]: So she's more than 18.
[SPEAKER_02]: it's divided breakdown.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we have all of Lynn, all of Livingston, all of Carroll, and then from Harding North, and then kind of at an angle to the northwest part of the county.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I don't actually have a lot of votes to come down here and get.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, I want to win when I can win.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because I want to win them all.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I saw the topic come through.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's one of our jobs is state reps.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's four counties involved.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's four chambers of commerce.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's four does their limited.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's, you know, there's all these organizations.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you have to pick and choose where you're going to go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any topic talking about youth is something I'm very passionate about.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I very much enjoy the food, but the topic's what got me here today.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as she pointed out, I am the only candidate in the race that bothered to be here today, so take that for what you will.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I'm a CPA.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do government audits and taxes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Heather and I are on the state committee, so we represent 19 counties right now in the Republican Party.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know this is not partisan, but I think that's an important part of my leadership skills.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we already know a lot of people in Jeff City.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, at this point, we're on the volunteer side.
[SPEAKER_02]: So when we go do work for them, we're doing it of our own good free will.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I guess I already know a lot of people down there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have experience in accounting.
[SPEAKER_02]: Government audits.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to go down and teach those guys how to do some math.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's people that are receptive to that out there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Talking about funding, we are losing our federal funding.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, COVID's over.
[SPEAKER_02]: That tap's turned off.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I know a lot of funding for programs like this was associated with that disaster.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that's over.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we have to learn to move forward and maintain these programs that are so vital to our communities with a lot less dollars, because we're not gonna have to support the federal government like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, I wanna be on the budget committee.
[SPEAKER_02]: As a CPA that does government audits, that makes sense to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I wanna make sure we're supporting the programs that are truly vital in making our state a great place to live.
[SPEAKER_02]: So.
[SPEAKER_07]: Jeremy, it's like you knew what the question was gonna be.
[SPEAKER_07]: It is.
[SPEAKER_07]: With state policies or legislative actions, would you support to reduce youth substance use and strengthen youth mental health services?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, I heard something.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we actually have, I'm an aggressive supporter of identifying and outlawing substances as they come up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think our AG has done a good job of trying to get that done, but government policy moves way too slow for this issue.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have a cultural problem in this country.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I can tell you what all the reasons I think those are, but we will start getting partisan really fast.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so I'm going to stay away from that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we have a culture issue in this country, and we really need to address that.
[SPEAKER_02]: The problem with lawmaking is it takes way too long to address a problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: These are working drugs.
[SPEAKER_02]: They hit the shelves before the adults in the room even know what they are.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so the kids are finding out about this stuff before we know what's even going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, think back.
[SPEAKER_02]: There were kids ingesting Tide Pods for crying out loud.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, who saw that coming?
[SPEAKER_02]: So we have to pay attention to what's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to impact the culture.
[SPEAKER_02]: Laws are good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Laws backstop what we believe is a society, but they don't move fast enough for this issue.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I have a few ideas on how we can address that culture when you ask me in the next one.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Let's get you to 7 a.m. today.
[SPEAKER_07]: Missouri Legislature legislators play a key role in regulating emerging substances and protecting youth from harmful products.
[SPEAKER_07]: What actions, if any...
[SPEAKER_07]: Would you support to address the youth access to substances such as e-cigarettes, hemp products, and emerging drugs?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, again, we talked about policy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, as the AG brings things up, that's essentially that officer's job to find out what's going on in the state.
[SPEAKER_02]: bring to the legislature for us to enact legislation, if she can't prosecute it already on an existing bill.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we will be responsive.
[SPEAKER_02]: The caucus will be responsive to what the AG's doing, and I think she's doing a pretty good job of that on the motion to murder that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the cultural problem we have in this state
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, I'm a reads around the water tank kind of dad.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's a biblical reference for those of you that know that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what we need to do, we need to challenge our kids more.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to challenge them to do more.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to challenge them to be more.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as we challenge our kids, they can learn how to fail gracefully.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think a lot of the problem with our society right now is our kids, they're so afraid to fail and try anything new.
[SPEAKER_02]: They won't go outside and touch grass.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to change the culture in this country and put our kids in the situations that are safe but challenging.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you need to know I've been in scouting for 35 years.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm currently the council commissioner of the Pony Express Council.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm in charge of all the program for the entire council across, I don't know, 35 counties.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that program is really where my youth interaction comes from.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to talk a lot about scouting
[SPEAKER_02]: I know I have three minutes, I'm gonna run over.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I've been active in that for 35 years, like I said.
[SPEAKER_02]: This program and programs like 4-H and FFA, they address this as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so I will be talking about scouting, that's my experience, but any youth organization
[SPEAKER_02]: can have a leadership methodology that really pushes this challenging kids to do better.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you do better, you're graded by it.
[SPEAKER_02]: What did you create?
[SPEAKER_02]: Who did you help pick up behind you that became a leader?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, these are not participation trophies when you raise a young person up and give them the tools to succeed.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the grading structure.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the output.
[SPEAKER_02]: So...
[SPEAKER_02]: George Fox University put out a memo on Eagle Scouts, merrily on a badge.
[SPEAKER_02]: The study finds that well-being, civic engagement, and character development all dramatically improve, not just for Eagle Scouts, but anyone who is involved in the scouting program.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why is this the case?
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't grow when we're comforted.
[SPEAKER_02]: To find balance
[SPEAKER_02]: the balance of an uncomfortable and challenging environment that is also safe, that's scouting.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's also 4-H.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's also FFA.
[SPEAKER_02]: It could also be FDLA if you're challenging the kids in that organization.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we need to add those challenges.
[SPEAKER_02]: Raising a Modern Day Knight by Robert Lewis talks about the coming of age rituals.
[SPEAKER_02]: In the book, the author relates the idea that conversation needs to happen with kids as they're maturing.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're now this age.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have these responsibilities.
[SPEAKER_02]: With those responsibilities come more freedom, but they also come with more responsibilities.
[SPEAKER_02]: And again, the book talks about another coming of age at 18.
[SPEAKER_02]: And to treat those kids differently, there are 13-year-olds, but that's another coming of age.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do we need to address?
[SPEAKER_02]: Now you're an adult.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now you have a lot more freedom, but you also have a lot more responsibility.
[SPEAKER_02]: In scouting, we also have that same thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that my timer?
[SPEAKER_02]: But these kids, we need to challenge them.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to put them outside.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anytime we can get a kid from an indoor activity to an outdoor activity, that's a game.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to jump to the end.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do have some stuff in here about girls, too, but I don't have time for that.
[SPEAKER_02]: As a member of the legislature, I'm prepared to issue a bill, put a bill up in the House, to allow any professional and recognized youth organization automatic access into the schools.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's critical for me because if that's where the kids are, that's where the kids have to be.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if we have good youth programs out there that provide character building, we need to visit our schools.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.